I have learned more about what it means
to be human civilian what are you want
to call it from the military than from
anybody else who doesn't we're in a
uniform which is I understand and I
learned a long time ago which is my own
sense of camaraderie and Brotherhood and
sisterhood and community is the thing
that helps me stay inspired is the thing
that saves me when I'm in the dark place
is the thing that motivates me and and
it's hard in this modern day and age to
find an intense sense of community or
love in in the general population and I
think technology makes it even more
difficult you know because we were
connected but we're not connecting and
when I started hearing stories from
people that I met in the military about
Brotherhood and sister and again we
called each other brothers you know I
wanted to learn quite frankly because my
complaint was why can't I have that you
know why can't we all have that why
can't everybody have that
you